hey guys it's Justine of here with
Marquez and we're in your studio
yeah we're in uh we're in these coasts
it's not so great outside but it's nice
and controlled in here so it's awesome
so you'd always like a PEZ listen you
think that Maddy can call meet Mac and
they met and they're friends now and
they follow each other i Instagram and
it's all great
it's the most incredible thing ever
here's a little clip though today I
thought we would do a week with iPhone
video because I've been meaning to do
one but at this point is it like three
or four weeks so we've had in three
weeks with the iPhone 11 so however many
weeks has been how has it been for you
pretty good so I've been on Space Gray
iPhone 11 Pro max I thought I might go
down to the smaller phone just for this
one but I just like the biggest screen
of course I had the midnight green one
that Apple gave us a review unit it's
fine I don't know how big of a midnight
green fan you are I've met some people
who love it not so much for me it's
definitely not my color preference of
choice but it was crazy because usually
how I gauge if something is cool or not
is if my real friends in real life start
messaging me and saying that's cool or
something like you're asking about it
yes so I had way more people than I ever
expected say that they love that color
I've had the same phenomenon of people
being like I want that green and then
that green is sweet I got the spacecraft
I got the silver and of course I did
this nice razor pink case to it it looks
white yeah very close and closer to
white than others because they had these
bright white colored phones in the past
but yeah this is the brightest one yet
but I'm curious like how that looks with
scratching cuz it's matte matte white
which is probably great for not showing
fingerprints yeah on the other side it's
insane actually this is really kind of
shocking at the house ratch this has
gotten I mean I know I'm usually pretty
abusive with things the front of my
midnight green one that I had yeah got
some serious scratching and that's
probably because I had it in the same
pocket as another phone they just like
to attack each other and that's fine
this one I've kept in great shape and
probably jinxing it but I don't have any
blemishes yet have you gotten the
battery life
improvement that they said they would
give I think the battery life is better
but it's hard to tell because I used to
have the battery charging case so that
extended it so much that I would have to
go back to just making sure I always
have like a movi charger or something
with me because I was so used to that
battery life yeah it does seem longer
it's pretty good I mean a lot of people
including me use the 10r a lot last year
so we're so used to this great battery
life but it is very good now on the
11pro max yeah that's name but better
odds pretty good I've also been enjoying
taking the wide-angle photos and
especially with the video I think as
long as you're in decent lighting it
makes a huge difference because you're
trying to take low-light wide-angle
photos it doesn't work out so well
they're not so great the lenses they're
having both guards keep him quiet
there's a wide-angle shot nice I got the
zoom in and the 2x the one thing that I
have noticed is the consistency though
throughout the three lenses because I
was doing a video with the oneplus 17 it
was crazy just to see the inconsistency
in those three camera lenses even the
oneplus 70 is better than some other
phones I've used this year I remember
the ROG phone to has an ultra wide and
it looks like a completely different
camera yeah I think there's one or two
others so calibrated from the factory
should look much better but like you
said there's no night mode on ultra wide
it's not quite as perfect I didn't
expect it to yeah but it's pretty good I
do really like it I also like the
front-facing having the the wide angle
facing it is pretty nice and I just
recently upgraded one of these phones
not gonna tell you which one to the beta
that has the deep fusion installed so I
want to sleep if you can see which one
is which so one of them's diffusion and
one of them is just a regular photo yes
okay I will try do you know what Ron
okay this'll be do I know which one oh
that's the kid okay sounds like you know
okay am i let's assume I should just
look at the I think you're probably
gonna have to zoom here you go okay so I
spoiler I've seen a couple of Tyler
Stallman tweets where he shared some
photos side by side and the biggest
difference is in dim lighting but not
quite night mode
without zooming in the only difference I
see is a little more dynamic range on
the left side just a little and when i
zoom I don't see much difference here
problem which is not even a problem at
all is the iPhone does take really good
photos this is a little further away so
maybe this will make a difference the
difference with the effusion I think is
it's just on all the time but it makes
more of a difference with lower light
photos and with high detail photos both
very sharp photos little prints going on
Mac spa okay I think this one might be a
little bit better of an example really
okay only because I've noticed something
that may look a little sharper okay I'm
looking at the foam in the background
and actually the foam in the background
it's so subtle but it's a tiny tiny bit
sharper on the white iPhone but look
over here like oh this looks also
sharper on this phone oh yeah so now the
the white bricks and the background on
the wall are definitely sharper on the
Left iPhone and that's less subtle yeah
and then look at Mac also a little
sharper over here we're really getting
down to like event in the ceiling and
the foam and things that aren't even the
focus of the photo become a guessing
person okay he's guessing this is a
completely a guess I'm gonna say that
the midnight green one has deep fusion
just because of the little extra bit of
done in the Grange and I think it has
something to do with HDR it's taking an
extra exposure right so I'm gonna go to
that great nice you are right it's so
crazy because like in this picture
specifically though you can tell like
Maddie looks a lot more crisp right in
contrast yeah if you know the that
filter not filtered but this slider in
Lightroom clarity and then there's also
the texture one but I if you dump up
clarity it also has that same so go yeah
but you can't cut italic in here like
and
the greatness of the carp yeah its
contrast here see now that I know what
I'm looking for and I know which one's
diffusion I'm gonna find all sorts of
other things the carpet though you can
definitely tell them a carpet but you
know what this says about these cameras
I was like they're already really good
they're already much better than last
year they're already top two arguably
the best smartphone camera out right now
yeah and that they're making it a little
bit better in certain scenarios with
this diffusion mode just says that
computational photography is great right
now smartphone cameras are great right
now no complaints no it's really great
so it says diffusion is designed to use
artificial intelligence and other
software tricks to improve the sharpness
of images by capturing frames of
differing exposures and merging them on
its own which is already what it's doing
this Mar HDR but it's doing it a little
bit more in a little bit better is it
supposed to only work for a medium to
low light scenes for a smart HDR night
mode handle extremely bright and
extremely dark see a photo yeah like I'm
just gonna go over here grab the
comparison like maybe take a picture of
like these suitcases like in a shadow
area yeah
I don't have DP so I can't help test it
oh that's medium light there's a
scientific testing
it's more dramatic a lot of people who
just light like this all the time
oh do a shot of me with the fusion so I
know what I look like
okay okay do you remember which one is
which I already don't so it's perfect
it's very very subtle with a left is
sharper warmer too hmm
left yeah that's it
it's so very subtle though that's like
that's what software updates are in
cameras it's always subtle like you get
a good camera you get your image
processing pipeline it's just gonna look
a certain way and then from there you
just do little tweaks and little things
and diffusion is another one of those
little tweaks and certain lighting
situations that makes it better
this light is so Moody okay so now but
yeah I mean other than that like the
phone has been pretty great I mean I
think the battery life is definitely
enhancing I just it's crazy because I
was 13 even if you have an older phone
it makes you feel like you have a new
phone entirely yeah so I was 13 when
great on older phones I'm curious if you
had in the beginning a whole bunch of
bugginess oh yeah as I did definitely
did still an Instagram I have some bugs
videos yes I can't add videos it all
drops are weird sometimes and sometimes
stories don't work and they've been
chopped off yes 13 had a bunch of
improvements and it's helped with older
phones but I also had some bugs yeah but
they're continuing to fix they found I'm
like a rapid pace of that I think
initially it was a little rough cuz
Jenna had probably one of the biggest
problems ever and I think she usually
does have a little trouble with her eye
Club backups do you want to come and
tell us real quick just pop in here say
hello it was just stuff I'm like the
white screen with the Apple and like to
the status bar so I did all the resets
and in all the recoveries and zippedy a
few oh but every time it reset it just
got stuck so for like four days
incredible battery life by the way the
phone used on a lot screen and there was
nothing I could do every time every said
it it just got stuck because you could
still reset it but then it was getting
stuck doing like the iCloud restore
restore which you could see in one of
the updates they
had a result for that huh put our phones
working great now they end up giving her
another one just because it was the
phone was on for like five days
that's a pride of being in tech is when
you see a software update and the little
like notes say like the exact issue
you've had yes what they fixed is
probably because you're wrong I know I
mean the backup took a really long time
because we were actually at camera camp
in the middle of nowhere in Montana yeah
so would the internet was not the best
with a bunch of tech people that just
got their new iPhones so we're all
trying to do the backup so that my
iCloud and I've taken like six days
y'all probably all related one tower oh
there was nothing around but it was
really fun cuz we all discussed unbox
our phones together it was like I mean
it was camera cam nice what we were
literally doing but it was really cool
uh yeah other than that I think
everything's been good I'm just looking
forward to more of the the updates for
iOS I mean that was the main the main
things that they wanted to fix and
improve with this phone or battery life
we've seen that cameras we got them
they're great in iOS and of course the
a13 ban I don't know if you've seen it
be faster at anything notably but famous
fine I mean playing games we've been
playing sneaky Sasquatch on Apple arcade
which is the best game ever
should I get a parking for a sneaky
Sasquatch yes you should okay I like it
because I have a problem with
microtransactions so if there's a game
that wants me to do upgrades like I'm
going to just kind of forget that this
is real money until it actually hits my
inbox and it's like what have you done
so just knowing that I'm paying one
price to play a game and not have to get
tricked into paying for other things by
bucks what I mean I mean it looks a
month they're just kind of crazy yeah
it's just if the games are good then
it's worth I mean I would have paid
$4.99 for this game anyway yeah so
that's definite
jenna is obsessed with it like just be
honest yes it's soaking it Jenna's
further along let's see your phone it's
hilarious so like you're a sasquatch but
you can dress like a human to try to
like how do you eat how do you
sneaky sabotage well you got to sneak
around yeah you sneak around so you
don't get caught okay
like arcade look a splash screen it's so
good
wait this seems like a game where you
just walk around doing things for fun
yes but you don't like win well we
haven't got that far yet okay because
the description says go fishing in a
lake play quick nine holes on the golf
course and eat some food that's just
things you can do okay you like a score
that goes up this new things probably or
something you just feel good about you
don't go to sleep look you'll pass out
and then the Ranger finds you and sends
you like back to life
come on here's my morning I think it is
for everyone
Adventure style okay so that's just like
a human right now that's a sasquatch
yeah so there he is this is how you
sneak why is the mayor of Bees by him
does he need help you have to save him
No oh he's happy there because he's
eating the honey so you can very like
steal people's picnic baskets so it
looks like that's already and it was a
fish so you can put the fish in your bag
and then you're gonna go to a picnic
just go around robbing people look yeah
I mean you're just thinking their food
assists you can live who peddle across
the lake so there's a human so usually
you have to sneak around and hide from
the humans what happens if you get
caught the Ranger takes you back to your
home and you go to sleep so that's movie
sasquatch I think everyone should get it
show you how I eat this is incredible
okay so you take oh you got a lot of
food yeah Wow Jenna's been fishing so
you're just like your mom you manually
have to do all this that's how I did I
can imagine as they were developing this
game knowing people are gonna love this
nature it's really great change
everything oh I love it
so yeah that's uh i phone 11 that we've
had for 3-4 weeks something like that
yeah it's the greatest phone they've
ever made it I enjoyed your iPhone 11
review which was that yes was a little
late it was it was it was still good
because it's I mean it's such a great
phone too easy it's just the phone they
obviously should make are you are used
pumped as I am about the 2020 iPhone oh
there's so many things this is what I
was in a pocket
with every new iPhone that's come at us
Wow the 20/20 iPhone might have USBC
might have have a pencil support maybe
five toes 5g might have a promotion 120
Hertz Oh at display it might have in
screen fingerprint might have touch ID
coming back might have reverse while I
was charging might have no not CH
there's all these things that it might
have so 2020 is gonna be insane it's a
great phone but I'm looking forward to
that yeah I mean we're gonna have a new
Xbox next year we're gonna have the
surface duo 2000 who knows what else is
coming out clad roadster oh my gosh I'm
excited yeah well guys thank you for
watching thank you so much for being my
video I think we're gonna be doing a
podcast here very shortly so make sure
you guys go check that out if it's out
and if not keep an eye out or an ear out
whatever it is that's what you shouldn't
do yeah
[Music]